IT SEEMS TO BE GAINING SUPPORT
FROM RUSSIAN CIVILIANS.
CNN'S PHIL BLACK HAS THE STORY.
>> Reporter: IT'S IMPOSSIBLE NOT
TO NOTICE, MANY OF THE RUSSIAN
VEHICLES INVADING UKRAINE CARRY
A DISTINCTIVE MARK, TRUCKS,
TANKS, FIGHTING, ENGINEERING AND
LOGISTICAL VEHICLES, THEY ARE
ADVANCING THROUGH UKRAINE WITH
THE LETTER "Z", PAINTED
CONSPICUOUSLY IN WHITE.
THE PEOPLE BEING INVADED HAVE
NOTICED.
HERE IN THE EASTERN UKRAINIAN
TOWN, AN ANGRY CROWD SWARMS
AFTER AND ATTACKS A SINGLE
VEHICLE.
ITS ONLY OBVIOUS CONNECTION TO
THE WAR THE LETTER "Z".
>> THERE IS A MILLION DIFFERENT
THEORYS ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS, BUT
I THINK IT IS A MARKING, JUST AN
EASY THING TO MARK, LIKE A
SQUARE OR A TRIANGLE.
>> Reporter: IN A WAR WHERE THE
WANNA-BE CONQUERORS ARE NOT
FLYING THEIR NATIONAL FLAG, THAT
SINGLE CHARACTER HAS TAKEN ON
SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE.
AT A RECENT GYMNASTICS WORLD CUP
EVENT, 20-YEAR-OLD RUSSIAN
COMPETITOR IVAN KULIAK ACCEPTED
HIS BRONZE MEDAL WEARING A "Z"
PROMINENTLY ON HIS CHEST.
HE WAS STANDING NEXT TO A
UKRAINIAN ATHLETE.
THE SPORTS GOVERNING BODY
DESCRIBED IT AS SHOCKING
BEHAVIOR.
BUT HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE THIS.
TERMINALLY ILL CHILDREN AND
THEIR CAREERS FORMED A GIANT "Z"
OUTSIDE A HOSPICE IN THE RUSSIAN
CITY.
>> THE CITY IS CO-OPTING YOUNG
CHILDREN TO BE PROPAGANDA
MECHANISMS FOR THEIR WAR.
IT IS DANGEROUS WHEN SMALL
LITTLE SYMBOLS BECOME PROXIES
FOR BEING A LOYAL CITIZEN IN AN
AUTHORITARIAN REGIME DURING A
TIME OF WAR.
THOSE WHO DON'T WEAR IT, THOSE
WHO DON'T SHOW THE "Z" COULD BE
TARGETED BY THE STATE.
>> Reporter: AND IN THIS HIGHLY
PRODUCED PROPAGANDA VIDEO,
RUSSIAN MEN WEARING THAT LETTER
DECLARE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
INVASION.
CHANTING, FOR RUSSIA, FOR THE
PRESIDENT, FOR RUSSIA, FOR
PUTIN.
AN AERIAL SHOT SHOWS A GIANT "Z"
MADE FROM THE ORANGE AND BLACK
OF THE ST. GEORGIANS RIBBON, A
SIGN OF GLORY USUALLY ASSOCIATED
WITH VICTORY OVER NAZI GERMANY.
BY ACCIDENT, OR DESIGN, A
CHARACTER THAT DOESN'T FEATURE
IN RUSSIA'S ALPHABET HAS BECOME
AN ICONIC SYMBOL OF PUTIN'S
IN